it looks like rochelle stouse is
officially off the market with her
selling sunset co-star
jason oppenheim i'm so excited on
wednesday jason told et
krishel and i became close friends and
it has developed into an amazing
relationship i care about her deeply and
we are very happy together
i think that's exactly right speculation
about the real estate moguls started
after krishel
posted these photos enjoying a luxury
vacane italy with jason
and their other co-stars brett oppenheim
mary fitzgerald
and her husband romaine bonet but it was
this steamy photo that had krishell's
followers turning heads
with the caption the jlo effect okay so
we made it we are
live from the helicopter and we are
having lunch
look at the view
jason's twin brother brett commented on
the pic writing love you krishell
thank you for making my brother happy
romaine who is married to jason's
longtime ex-girlfriend mary wrote
so happy for you guys finally people
will stop with jason and mary hopefully
it also seems like this trip turned into
a double date with both couples enjoying
a helicopter ride through italy
before going public with jason krischell
was previously married to this is us
star justin hartley the couple finalized
their divorce in november
after two years of marriage i mean come
on give me a break right what a vision
this is incredible it's incredible in
september krishele opened up to e.t
about what it was like sharing her
heartache on season three of selling
sunset
yeah it's tough you know it's it's
probably not something that
in your regular life you would choose to
do you know what i mean it's
crazy world that is reality television
and um
i will say so much good has come out of
it
that it balances out the negative
you know i'm sure can go the other way
as well but in this instance i feel like
it gave a little purpose to the pain
yeah because people connected with it
and
um you know at the end of the day um
the last thing i ever want to do is you
know talk bad about somebody or anything
like that
i i really want to try and focus on
positive and in it
you know if things don't work out that
that's terrible but you know
i don't want to i don't want to ever
like be tearing somebody down or
anything like that and so i just feel
like
with the show and watching it back it's
just it's tough
but i but i'm excited to just kind of
move on from
yeah talk about that the real estate
agent also revealed that she's
definitely ready for the next chapter of
her life which we'll likely get to see
when season 4
of selling sunset returns to netflix
later this year
you know what i think everything leads
you to
where i'm at today and so looking at it
you know now
you know it kind of feels like you know
maybe everything happens for a reason
and i'm in such a great space right now
this is so fun i could have never
expected that this is kind of
where my life would have led me to and
so i certainly
am grateful for everything right now